it's hard to go through something so
public and have people speculate and
and want to respond and want to
set the record straight but i think at
the end of the day i've truly gotten to
a place where
i know the truth my family knows the
truth my friends and the truth and god
knows the truth and that's enough for me
your latest project 29 you are getting
fantastic criticism from
critics you are getting fantastic
responses from
fans how does all the praise for your
work how does that feel
i think when you
dream of doing this for a living and you
put your heart and soul out for the
whole world to see and kind of put it
out there for display
and you have that kind of a reaction
where fans are like
me too or i relate to this or i needed
this or
critics think that what you're doing is
worthy of being written about or
anything like that it's uh really really
special
and i'm just so happy that it's this
music that's getting
this kind of attention this new project
of years 29 it is
a beautiful compilation of extremely
vulnerable
songs
[Music]
it ain't always gonna be a clean break
and it's okay
whatever it takes these days
folks have called it a divorce diary a
breakup record
but how would you like to describe it i
think it's
right on time to be exactly who i am as
an artist
i think that you know i lost my producer
busby and
that's a lot of where some of this
quest to find myself came from in the
middle of quarantine
he was a pot producer from the bay area
and i think i took him as country as he
was ever going to go
especially with i hope you're happy now
which is the last song that we worked on
together
and what's so amazing about the new
collaborators that i've found in
shane macanally and josh osborne who
wrote a lot of this with me and produced
it is
they love 90s country like i do and
that's what got them
excited about working with me and so i
feel like when i look at this music i
just see oh my gosh this is
the music that i moved to nashville to
make this is what five-year-old carly
dreamt of doing when she used to say she
was going to sing on the grand ole opry
oh my gosh and look at you girl and at
16
dropping out of high school so you could
go and do
five shows a week at dollywood to
achieve your dream so yeah what would
you tell that 16 year old girl
now oh my gosh i remember doing my
schooling in between shows at dollywood
and
all i ever knew was country music what
made me so happy it's why my parents let
me
drop out of school after my freshman
year wow they knew this is what i wanted
and i would just tell her to hang on
because she has no idea how many of her
country music dreams are going to come
true
29 is encompassing the 29th
year of your life 29 is the
[Music]
just how pivotal was that 29th year for
you
huge i think it was a moment that
when you go through life you go through
seasons that
maybe shock you in good ways and in bad
and
29 was kind of the year that i felt like
i was really coming into myself
and found a lot of stability
and quite honestly the rug was pulled
out from under me in so many ways
musically professionally personally and
this music and why i wanted to call it
29 is because this is
me going through this quest of trying to
stay
alive in a lot of ways and trying to
find my way and not give up
and still have hope and i think for a
lot of people even though
this is my story i think they can relate
to that because life doesn't always turn
out the way you think it's going to
we all go through hard times and i think
that
when you're in the public eye you want
to maintain this level of
i call it instagram perfect and
you want everybody to think you have it
all together and yet here i am with
i hope you're happy now climbing the
charts changing my whole world musically
in a positive way
but i have no idea what's coming next
musically and
my personal life is crumbling and i
think about her
and i think about how she felt like she
was going to die
and i think about everything that has
happened
in one year and it just is a testament
to hold on and still believe and to keep
pushing through because
i really did think i was going to die at
times i really did
and i'm so much better because of it all
are you anticipating a response
or reaction from the person who broke
your heart or have you received a
response
since your music has now been out there
i haven't i think that
you can't think about those things to be
honest with you
i'm not doing anything differently than
i did when i came onto the scene with
every little thing
i thanked the guy who broke my heart
when i won the cmt
breakthrough video of the year to the
guy that broke my heart
thank you and then i went on to
tell you about my apology where i broke
somebody's heart and i hope you're happy
now
it's all on me it's my mistake
i think it's easy for people to look at
this and
feel like they know what this is all
about but
it's just what i've always done and
i feel like i i had to be honest with
myself and honest to my fans
because i think if i wasn't being honest
in writing all of this they wouldn't
have believed me
and you just can't think about that
stuff yeah you're turning
tragedy into triumph that is for sure um
do you feel like there was one song in
particular that you find
challenging be it in the recording
process
or singing live on the gram or maybe in
person
eventually hopefully to a concert group
of people
i think that show me around was a
special moment when i get there
she'll track me down and show me
around i remember in the studio it was
the first
song that we all worked on and all of
the musicians in the room
plus my new producers and myself
we were listening to the demo of it and
everybody started crying because
everybody knew
they miss him everybody missed him he
was loved in the community he was
your producer yes lesbian and
i wrote that song for busby and he died
so tragically at the age of 43
um from glioblastoma brain cancer and i
remember
we all were just it was such a
moment of musicians missing him it is
oh it is a beautiful song though
liability though is one that i feel like
gonna have a lot of people talking
[Music]
when you say it's no one
it's funny no one calls me
this late what do you hope though that
they take from that song
i'm proud of that song as a songwriter a
lot of people would never think that i
brought that idea
i remember being in the writer's room
and i had it written in my phone
liability your lie ability and i was
kind of like this
and i was like oh my gosh you know shane
macanally and josh osborne i always say
they own the radio
yeah uh yeah i was like they're either
gonna think this is super cool or so
stupid
and i remember i just was like hey guys
i have this idea i don't know you know
because you want to like backpedal a
little bit
and shane literally
jumped off of the couch and was like
you're kidding me
and it was like this moment as a
songwriter that you want so badly
especially just as an artist to kind of
like prove yourself and i
we wrote it super fast but it was so
cool that's what i take away from that
song
but with that song a lot of people will
be speculating who's it about
you know all the backstory and
everything there has been speculation
that there was infidelity
involved in your formal relationship and
that's why you filed for divorce
will you ever do you foresee do you
perceive that there will ever come an
aspect or a time in your life when
you're like
i want to share this aspect of the story
and why you guys got divorced
i think that there are details
that are not meant for anyone else i
think that there are
lyrics that people can speculate all
they want
but the fun in it is that i know what's
real and what's not
um i think that i can rest
it's hard to go through something so
public and have people speculate and
and want to respond and want to
set the record straight but i think at
the end of the day i've truly gotten to
a place where
i know the truth my family knows the
truth my friends know the truth and god
knows the truth and that's enough for me
i think we were very public in our
relationship
and i think that's also shown me that
maybe that's too far
yeah do you regret that being so public
i think i
regret it and will definitely move
forward differently
just because i think but when you're so
excited and you're so in love
i was in love i was happy i never want
to
act like i wasn't in love because i was
that was real for me but i think
there are just parts of your life that
maybe should remain
private day one is another song of yours
that is
getting through the grief the heartbreak
just
taking those next steps after breaking
up yeah i'll get over you
if i just get through day one
how is your heart now i don't know when
this happened
but somewhere in the last
month of getting ready to
put this music out i remember when we
were
working on day one and that ending
verse where it talks about you might
even smile when you see them
you'll just be somebody i knew if i can
just get through day one and i had this
full breakdown because i realized
i was there and
sometimes it just hits you and you
realize oh my goodness i'm gonna be okay
and i remember that moment where i felt
like i couldn't take a breath and i
couldn't do it and i didn't know
how i was ever going to get through day
one and what a beautiful thing to be
able to sit here and look at you and say
i'm
my heart's good i'm hopeful and
happy are you ready to dip your toe in
the dating pool again
i've been on dates i i don't want
anybody to think successful
successful i'm fantastic um i'm not
you're not grandmama living in the shoe
here with your 20 cats
i don't want anybody to think that i'm
like i don't believe in love ever again
i'm hopeful to find love
i think i deserve real love yes you do
and i i look forward to finding that
you